25 years of hits live at the HOA Ward's
the presentation of Germany's most
important music awards on Thursday was a
gala event and this year there were some
extra performances
the event featured German as well as
international stars it's an event
Finland to be able to come back on the
25th birthday as an amazing thing for me
and I'm very honored to be here it's as
old as me we're both 25 which is very
cool and we both love music it's super
big first of all because the German
market is huge is Germany's most
important music award Sarah Connor took
home an Edgehill for best German female
artist like last year Elena Fisher
received the most i chose this year she
took home four of them the surprise
winner of the evening was german singer
songwriter yiannis who won 38 ohs DJ
robin schulz made off with to the main
factor in deciding who wins an 80 is
sales figures for the previous year it's
not it's always a reflection of the
musical year and that's why it's so
diverse and that's why it caters to
everything whatever people like the most
and what they found most interesting
the echoes got their start as a small
industry gathering but attending the
echo soon became a must for German
musicians and it's Fame also spread
abroad more and more international stars
attended including Led Zeppelin Jon Bon
Jovi Depeche Mode Ricky Martin and
Anastasia after hoddesdon config
disadvantages it's not an award for
creativity creativity plays little role
this is an award oriented towards unit
sales there's no jury that needs to
consider what was most important best
and most relevant musically that year
yeah but the ceremony itself could be
creative bringing together the likes of
german band Rammstein with us shock
rocker marilyn manson in 2012 2014
featured a duet by Elena Fisher and
british singer James Blunt the 8 o's
have become a television event a perfect
platform for bands like you two to debut
new songs British superstar Adele has
also been a guest at the SEO Awards
several times
as has Irish singer-songwriter Enya who
performed this year I was here firstly
in 2001 where I received her an award
and now they I could celebrate in 25
years it's so wonderful to be back here
to be nominated and also to get to
perform German pop and rock has also
grown more popular over the past 25
years in 2007 tokio hotel drew throngs
of young fans repeat visitors with 10 8
oz each include herbert grönemeyer the
band Rammstein adhere the toten hosen
but no one comes close to Helene
official with the total of sixty nine
shows she set a record on Thursday
that was closely followed by the Castel
chodesh Batson from south to roll with
13 atos over the past 20 years we've
taken a clear step towards what I'd call
europeanization people increasingly
accept music created and conceived in
Germany even when the lyrics are
recognizably German we began to catch up
in ways that we couldn't have
anticipated and that's very gratifying
things have changed quite a bit these
days even international stars are
acquiring a smattering of German dunking
on la funds ok digestion SS Abba global
extremist with 9 8 o's Robbie Williams
is the most successful international
performer the issue is viejas this is
the issue is what it is oh it's an award
that honest people who were successful
during the year that's okay that's fine
what's lacking is a really good critics
price to name like the ticket price
there's always time for emotional
moments at the awards this year hommage
was paid to David Bowie who died in
January an artist whose echo will never
fade